in today's world it can feel like
there's no space for silence like we're
always required to be responding to
something to be saying something new
whether that's answering a text or an
email a tweet a whatsapp message or even
the phone
my name's harriet shawcross i'm a
filmmaker and a journalist
and i think we would all benefit from a
little bit more silence in our lives
[Music]
one of the reasons i'm interested in
silence and in what can and can't be
said is that when i was a teenager
there was about a year when i didn't
really talk to people at school i would
answer direct questions if a teacher
asked them
or i would read out loud but the kind of
communication that makes us human
spontaneous conversations sharing jokes
was something that i wasn't able to do
and it had a huge impact on me and was
really formative in terms of how i
relate to people both professionally and
personally
so what's so great about silence we're
in the course of researching my book
i came across several studies into the
impact that silence can have on both the
body and the brain
in one study involving mice silence was
shown to promote the growth of brain
cells in the part of the brain
responsible for memory related to the
senses
scientists played mice a selection of
sounds including baby mouse cries
white noise and silence and observed
that during silence there was cell
growth in the hippocampus
another study looked at the impact of
listening to music on the body
and the researchers found that if
silence was inserted into a track of
music
the blood pressure dropped the heart
rate reduced and the subject relaxed
much more than when listening to a
relaxing piece of music
this only happened when the silence was
inserted in the middle of the tune
itself
it didn't work for silence at the
beginning or end of the experiment
so there's something about silence that
comes in the middle of noise that's
particularly beneficial
so silence can also enable people to
actually say things that they've never
been able to say before i looked into
the formation of the samaritans a
support service for people that are
feeling despairing or suicidal the
service was set up in the 50s by a vicar
and he started it because he had to
conduct the funeral of a young girl
who'd taken her own life
the reason she took her own life is that
she'd started her periods and thought
she contracted some terrible disease and
was dying
she was deeply ashamed of what was
happening to her and had no one to talk
to about it
it was this that inspired the vicar chad
barra to set up the samaritans as he
didn't want people to feel that there
were things that they couldn't talk
about particularly things that they were
ashamed of
they believe that you should be able to
sit with someone no matter what they're
going through without feeling the need
to answer back or offer solutions or
problem solve
and a really central way of doing that
is through using silence and giving them
space to explain what's going on for
them
and frankly if normal conversations
could involve a little bit more silence
like that
i think the world will be a much happier
place so silence is also at the heart of
most major world religions
in buddhism silence is really highly
valued and conversation can be seen as
something that gets in the way of our
experiences
and if you strip away all of that
language you're left with a deeper
understanding of
your own experiences in the world and
your connection to other people
but can too much silence be a bad thing
there's a condition known as acidity
which was experienced by monks who spent
prolonged periods in silence
and it's basically distinguished by a
feeling of torpor of not being able to
do anything
and that's specifically associated with
spending long periods of time without
speaking to anybody
i also spoke to people who'd spent more
time than probably most of us would want
to in silence
one of them was a buddhist who spent
nine months on a silent and solitary
retreat
and the silence had a really profound
effect on him after a certain amount of
time he felt like he was losing control
of both his mind and his body
he actually felt like he was having a
heart attack he knew logically he just
pulled a muscle in his chest
but without anyone to say i've pulled a
muscle in my chest to
the pain that he was feeling the
sensations of panic meant that he
actually really thought that he was
dying
and the only way that he could snap out
of that was by calling a friend of his
and it was only once he had words and
language to attach to what was happening
to him
that he was able to make sense of it and
eventually feel better so that buddhist
actually described silence to me as
being like love
it's something that instinctively we all
feel we want and need in our lives
but silence like love is really strong
medicine and it can actually
completely tear you apart thanks for
watching
if you enjoyed that be sure to check out
these videos next and if you haven't
already
hit the subscribe button and click the
bell to get a notification each time we
upload a new video